try to device ready flights and imaging
technique in order to visualize the
biological process better with higher
spatial resolution and also be able to
image and longer and faster to capture
the details of how biology happened at
protein level or cellular level or
multicellular all that information is a
fortune
I think it can lead us to a complete
understanding in bowel size and in
relate to our our health and for
clinical applications this is that
diagnostic etc because Stevie Ray and
then that means you can correlate you
can connect this two billion dollar in
and trillion dollar business and that is
the impact I think all the future I'm
looking for that's why we are giving our
entire design software everything to
research labs for non-commercial use we
are happy very happy actually we are
honoring the - to do that - to reach
return of knowledge to the society not
only to to China or mean to to Arawa in
the world know someone's opinion may
contradict yours what is my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we in what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we're on site
at the beautiful West Lake University in
Hangzhou China we are now going to be
talking about tiling light sheet
microscopy we have dr. Liang gouge oh hi
everyone hi Lana thank you so much for
joining thank you for having me
yes really appreciate you coming on and
thanks thank you very much those who
don't know the Jung's background
it's an associate professor at Westlake
University pioneering new optical
methods enabling rapid high-resolution
3d imaging of expanded biological
specimens and you can find the links in
the bio below ayoung let's start things
off with one of our favorite questions
we like asking our guests what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
well that's a big question
I think definitely we are trying to
understand our life we are trying to
understand each other better and we are
trying to build a better world for
everybody for ourselves I think that's a
goal and the direction of the ward of
course there there are a lot of back and
forth possibly but in the end I think we
are going to reach there basically we
are going to reach place that is that
worked better for everyone and for
everybody hopefully can get there right
destiny yes hahaha and what do you think
is an important skill for us to embody
to ensure that we continuously improve
our civilization I think one of the most
important thing is perhaps again let's
say so basically of course in order to
achieve something you have to basically
be regulated and be regulated means to
regularly on to part of our life
why is regulation on others the second
is regular
our selves so basically we perhaps
cannot put a lot of hope in how to
regulate other people's behavior but
what we can put our efforts in or what
we can do better certainly is we can
regulate ourselves better if we truly
understand the meaning of life
understand what we are where we are
marching on and what's a goal of our
life I think we can regulate ourselves
better and if mean wife they have better
understanding better communication make
sure that on everybody understand each
other and in the end I think we can
reach that goal
by better regulation of ourselves yes
perhaps that yeah if it's sing about
what's the most important part perhaps
that's a very important thing yes yeah
yeah that's definitely at the top though
some of the oldest advice know thyself
and also do really good job at
regulating your emotions your goals or
aspirations your family relationships
your career the community around you
this is very very important critical
Ally focus regulation of the cell even
that go ahead let's talk about you as a
child so let's talk about your journey
where were you born how did you get
interested in optics and science ok so I
was born in Shanxi Province in China and
at 1 year old my parents moved to most
western part of China because of their
job the province called a chignon
province of China so there's a lot of
minority people and then I moved there
at one and grew up there onto our 17th
after that I was admitted into Shanghai
University in Beijing and then I went
there for college I spent 7 years in
that University my major was cut
it's called precision instrumentation so
I built in I learned how to build
instrument I got my bachelor and master
degree in that university so it's a good
university at some point let's say in
most people's mind is very good in
university I do or Cuevas but there are
something I think I didn't learn during
that period time I was training a lot of
how to optimize a lot of details I was
training electronics mechanics
everything but in the end I don't know
what kind of instrument I want to build
I have very little understanding on
instrument industry because it was not
so let's say developed in China at that
period time in maybe year of 2000 and
then I was thinking about why I'm doing
this and then I searched around I
started to what kind of areas need more
instrument and at that point in the time
I learned actually analytical
instrumentation is a very let's say an
important industrial area and they do
need all kinds of instrument and to
analyze the chemicals we are dealing
with every day and one of the techniques
called mass spectrometry so basically it
analyzed molecular weight and by doing
that we can know what chemicals are
there in the samples and now wow I
thought that's a great direction I mean
while my wife went to the US and she
went to the Purdue University and and
fortunately there was a very famous
professor called Graham cooks in an
chemistry department of Purdue
University and he was expert in mass
spectrometry especially our
instrumentation mass spectrometry this
is how to build better mass spectrometer
and my major was precise precision
instrument so it's a perfect match and I
think wow I can go to that department
and learn what's a real instrument that
people need and I can maybe find a
better go of my life and learn how what
I want to do in the rest of my my life -
richer better career right so I also
applied that University and indeed
joined our crab cooks lab and doing a
mass spectrometry doing my PhD that was
from 2005 to 2009 until I graduated so
indeed during that period time I
I build let's say the first class let's
say the instrument I built called
miniature mass spectrometer the reason
that direction is important is because
the conventional mass spectrum they are
huge
very large me oh you're early typically
weights about 100 kilogram or even more
meanwhile there are a lot of
applications you want a very quick
measurement phasma fast response
measurement of the chemical environment
for example in industry site for example
another important application is in
astronomy so we send satellite to
different for example to Mars right but
we do want to know what's the chemicals
on Mars so the bad ones the best way
actually indeed send a spectrometers to
Mars to measure the chemical components
that planet and then of course you need
to build a very small but precise mass
spectrometer in order to do that and so
that's a major motivation of my research
during that period time and I indeed
you're very small mass spectrometers
well there's only 5 kilogram and it can
do a lot of awesome things and actually
in that environment a very important
device called the discontinuous
atmospheric pressure interface to
introduce eyes from atmosphere to vacant
space efficiently with a very small
equipment and actually that device was
used on the latest mass rower build by I
think European whata EPS so basically as
it's called
ExoMars 2020 it's going to be launched
in yeah next year and yes that device
was actually used in the latest mass
role or it can be sent to Mars but
anyway so that was what I was doing
during my PhD I think it was pretty
successful I learned many things in that
lab and then of course in 2000 I equated
from Purdue right but
let's stay on the subject for a little
longer than woman this shirt yes so
miniaturizing mass spectrometry yes so
taking the Machine size from a hundred
kilograms right and bringing you down to
five kills so it can do things like go
on satellites to Mars is that thing
because it's expensive to wash things
into space
is that bad yeah and so that's one of
them
relatable examples uh-huh and then also
just this move in general so your your
wife was first writing first to Purdue
yes following okay cool cool and then
what was it like when you first arrived
and you were immersing in the United
States culture what was that like and
also what was it like when you
discovered that you could miniaturize
some machine that was 100 kilograms down
to five how did you come up with those
ideas right so let's first let's talk
about what's my feeling why first went
to the u.s. so basically I until I went
moment I went to the United States I
haven't been traveling to any other
country so the in high war is quite
that's a very fresh very mister place to
me so I was very excited to be basically
everything happening there when I
arrived is is is very attractive very
new to me and I I think I adapted to the
environment quickly because I I think
let's say one of the most impressive
things I think everybody was so nice
gentle implied that's perhaps one reason
I could adapt into the environment
quickly and also and the other thing I
realized is I had a lot of freedom and
to do what I want
although I was paid I was supported by
Purdue University by dr. Graham cooks
his research assistantship so I need to
do research in Islam but actually I was
not required to do some specific saying
I I do have the space to sing about my
own ideas to find topics that I sing
interesting and what I need to do so
that's something I most impressive to me
so basically the freedom and how nice
how supportive the environment was why
arrived in the US and also the other
thing is I think because and my period
of time even I think even by now when we
think about the most advanced technology
we also always think about the United
States right so as a part be also when I
was a teen wah I think we did some
pretty awesome project but one thing we
are now sure is we don't have the we
didn't have the confidence about the
level of our project was we don't know
what's up at what the word word first
class project what's the best project or
what's the frontier really frontier
problems people are working out and we
have no clue of that but after I went to
the United States enjoying the dr.
Graham cook slept because he was a
leader in that area I knew what all this
is the most frontier project that people
are working on and this is a
cutting-edge technology and then I have
the confidence of what I'm working on
represents the highest level of this
field I think is that's very important
for the development of young sunny space
basically establish the confidence of
your own ability your own vision your
your own judgment I think that's
something I can I mean from the
experiences are in Purdue and after that
me because you know you are working on
the most let's say frontier project and
you do can release your your mind right
you you you can think about whatever
crazy ideas to work on instead of
suspecting whether this is something
make sense at all right because the you
know the status of the of the frontier
so anything that is new into your money
new it is
new for the entire field right and you
can just move forward with that idea I
think that something very important to
me and I think to anyone who was trained
in the United States yes know where the
frontier is and then have the confidence
in the vision to do the work at the
frontier so then you guys how did you
have the foresight to say okay how do we
bring this down the mass spectrometry
down in right so basically that is
project not started by myself so
basically it it has a history after this
project has a history go back to maybe
60s there was a scientist in University
of Minnesota I'm sorry I can not
remember his full name
he's a italian-american I think his last
name of first name is Alfredo
so hey basically he was a part of that
Manhattan Project right that nuclear
projects basically used mass battery
geometry to separate uranium to make it
more to purify the real chemical and
then at some point in the 1960s 70s the
United States start that aerospace
project of course - and then people has
a need to sense that our mass analyzer
into the space and he started that idea
say if we can build miniature mass
spectrometers and then we can actually
have certain certain goals and indeed
people start to build a different
version of mass spectrometers and make
them small and then send them to space -
actually many different planets but of
course the techniques is developing
right so we can build better and better
instrument with more analytical ability
to analyze more complicated chemicals
for example at the beginning people
would be happy to see whether there is
water whether is there oxygen or carbon
dioxide what's a concentration of them
in the atmosphere right but at some
point people would like to see whether
there's a mineral acid
there could be protein or more
complicated molecules on those planets
so we can learn more about the
environment of those planets right and
then so by inherits the previous
knowledge and also be on the other hand
because I was training instrumentation
so although I was in a chemistry
department a lot of my colleagues or
many others they were chemists but I'm
actually McKenna's or let's say in stay
house so I build the instrument I know
how to make those things happen so it's
it's just so natural to me and actually
it's a yeah that's why I said I think I
suddenly find a place that I can apply
what I learned into the into some very
important and interesting our project so
yes things happened so natural to me I
that's my feeling
another thing I think I have to
appreciate is dr. Graham cooks has a lot
of collaboration with industrial
companies for example the summer Fisher
now customer Fisher at that point there
was a mass spec company called Finnegan
thermal Finnegan's they build let's say
the best mass spectrometers in the world
and they have the biggest market share
at this point so they do have a lot of
collaborations and then from that
collaboration I think I also learned as
an organization of big companies how
they are starting a project why how do
they make decision about whether they
want to start initiate a product or not
me what going to be kind of a resources
going you're going to need in order to
make that happen kind of thing so indeed
yes
so basically certain part of my training
happen naturally about my research about
my instrumentation ideas etc many of
them are just I think they emerge
gradually during my education why learn
more and more stuff during those years
and and also when you are in
environments that you are encouraged to
sink actively because I do have the
freedom read because he my adviser was
so busy he barely have had happy to talk
to me so when you are in that
environment you you you can sing freely
and you have the resource and indeed me
it's um
yeah then they're not much better
environment like that to really produce
some good research results yes yeah yeah
I'm freely having the resources and also
those collaborative partnerships that
you were talking about exactly crucial
let's go to the postdoc that sure so
this was at Howard Hughes Medical
Institute yes
and so what were you doing there so I
was building a licensed microscope there
and try to basically try to diverse 3d
flights and imaging technique in order
to visualize the biological process
better with higher spatial resolution
and also be able to image in London and
faster to capture the details of how
biology happened at protein level or
cellular level or multicellular oh yeah
actually this is also an interesting
transition because mass spectrometry has
nothing to do with rice on microscopy
right mmm that's another thing actually
important decision in my career so the
reason that after I graduated from
Purdue me let's say I learned several
things
I mean why why you make decision to do
summers to do certain things to decide
what is your career I think you have to
find something you enjoy right if you
don't enjoy that you you cannot do it
well you have you have to find something
that you think it's important you can
convince yourself to spend a lot of time
on that thing right and then you have to
single in what way you can make impact
right and Mitchell mass spectrometry or
means you might expect mass spectrometer
it's a very cool project but at that
point I don't see how it can influence a
lot of people because yes since then
something to Marseille is very important
but only very small amount of people
going to cure that thing right
and me this is the benefits of being
able to walk my ology exactly is so so I
think indeed I want to choose more
employment projects so basically
everybody wants to have more positive
impact on the society on the environment
right so I decided to change my own
research erection let's say the other
reason I decided to quit from mass
spectrometry field is because of mass
spectrometers a very complicated
instrument and it's very
well-established field because it's a it
has hundreds of billion dollar market
that's why there are a lot of big
companies like Angela like so no waters
they spend a lot of resources in their
own R&D and for academia lab in order to
compete with them to build a better
instrument it's almost a mission
impossible because they have very
experience for experienced engineers
they have people work small trivial / a
small project are very promising for
many many years improve the performance
right there's no way for a research lab
to compete with industry company in that
level basically in any well-defined
regime of science or any technology
meaning damages cannot compete with
companies that's something I learned
because they have resources and momentum
to optimize things better ray and I
learned I have to pick something that
important has big impact but but not
that attractive to to those big
companies and I thought life sciences
perhaps I feel die I should step into
and imaging is something seems so
interesting because I was always amazed
by those images and then yes that's why
I made a decision to get into flies in
my cross P and then the reason is where
you want to do that post I'll write
because in this that if you know let's
say if your period you want to do
something completely different from your
PhD if during a poster you are having
very big risks first nobody's going to
want you because why right because
you cannot do anything like that the
second thing is you are risk to yourself
your own career array and then although
I know actually but of course the
important thing is you want to convince
people because for myself is if I have
interest in something if I can convince
myself to do something I will spend my
time I would do my best and after I
created from Purdue I think I picked up
that confidence that I can if I want to
handle it while I wanted to do it well I
I could I could do it that's something I
was pretty confident at that point of
time and start high neural plasticity to
to be able to make this right right and
then I checked all those labs about
which lab are doing let's say frontier
imaging what's up frontier imaging labs
and then so occasionally I read a report
about aerobatic so yeah if a chance you
should check his story very interesting
very um so so he was such a inspiring
person that he has he had actually a
very difficult career in his I think I
think it's a difficult successful but
difficult because he changing his career
many times he used to be scientists and
then used and then became a mechanical
engineering his father's Factory
mmm self-employed or jobless let's say
and then come back to academia and
become a win Nobel Prize what inspired
me is that live of course in Tucson are
hidden our Nobel Prize but he published
very important paper about
super-resolution
the paper actually gave him a Nobel
Prize and then I saw the increase the
resolution with Mike Ross yeah break the
diffraction limit and then the
diffraction yeah so basically regular
weakens our resolution of rice and the
imaging is dominated by depression limit
of light right we can see maybe 200
nanometers that's the best we can see
but with his method we can drive that
resolution down to about 10 nanometer
resolution that's a reason so that's his
idea and
indeed actually our practice that I
didn't make that made it happen that why
he won't Nobel Prize and he did a lot of
other important researches in his career
as well and explain this to us why is
there a diffraction limit with like oh
so basically the light is actually an
electrical magnetic wave ray and then if
it's a wave them me it means it has
certain wavelengths and then in order to
create image basically we need to use
that a wave to create a focus right
basically we need to crack a lot of
light and focus them into a spot because
that light has a certain valence it
won't be passed the minimum spot size
you can create with that light cannot be
less than half of the wavelengths of the
light and then that is called
diffraction limit for example if we use
green light to do image and then the
wavelength subsequent light is perhaps
somewhere around 520 nanometer and then
we divide that by 2 is about 260
nanometers of course if we can if we use
different amine buffer we can push that
resolution a little bit lower to maybe
200 kind of saying but that's the best
you can do without doing anything else
but with his master you are able to push
them push the resolution down to 10
nanometers and is that going further on
the electromagnetic spectrum past the it
passed the violet is that are we going
how how do you get down past 200
nanometers that method was very clever
the it's actually so basically there is
a requirement let's say let's start a
lipid make a story liberal under
basically how we can see a stuff let's
say see yourself say the structures in
gufa yeah because they don't emit light
right so there is no way we can see them
by any let's say equipment or by our
bare eyes resulting and without doing
anything to the sample we have to shine
by added and image yeah and then the
more important thing is we have to add a
probe as something that can emit
and who the objects that we want to
study so what people did was another
Nobel Prize work actually called GFP
it's a Roger Tsien won that prize little
bit and a few other Sankey's so
basically you label molecular probe a
protein probe genetically to the
molecule you want to study and that
probe is cut Malak lets GFP so basically
wine you shine laser through that
molecule and that molecule going to emit
frightens and by clad that process you
will be able to see that molecule right
but if you just do that
regular observation you won't be able to
exceed the diffraction limit unless one
thing you can do is if those labels if
they emit one by one not emit similar at
the same time so basically what you're
the images you're going to see is just a
random spot right however if you know
that your molecules are emitting light
one by one and you see random spread is
spot you know that it's about the center
of spot is a molecule ray and then you
can use that image to localize the
position of that molecule and you repeat
this process to let all molecules shine
emit in sequence and then you can find
the location of all your friends and
probes right and in the end you create
image that passes spirit a pasear
the fresh limit of light so basically
this is Eric's idea hey I really make a
specific part of the cell like a protein
fluoresce it's like an image it right
and that is already past the diffraction
that is not positive element but the way
you collect the signal and find the
location of the net molecule is a key is
passed to diffraction it exactly okay
because we're a protein in a cell is
about how many nanometers the protein
alpha sorry about four to five nanometer
as well that's a typical size of alpha
protein there are larger ones smaller
but I feel nanometers today yes so the
first your first like aha moments were
that you can do a microscopy at even sub
200 nanometer levels and you wanted to
go even deeper into understanding how to
do that rather build new tools yeah to
enable us to go deeper than right
actually a little different directions
but anyway that was Eric's work right
and that was what inspired me to join
his lab because I knew wow this is such
a smart person and it is so cool and I
although I knew nothing but my crusty
because he was not that famous as a pure
time I knew I had a chance to join his
lab and I knew this is must be a person
I like because he has been falling paste
dream in his career and I like this idea
so I think we can perhaps we have some
echo each other right and then I write
an evening email to him and he invited
me to to interview and then I joined his
lab and then I start to work on sweetie
fries and imaging which is actually
another dimension of imaging let's think
about this way if you want to understand
the life right you will need to
understand two things you need to kind
of information one is a spatial
resolution right basically you have to
see the details or you have to see the
object and the other dimension is you
want to see the process you want to see
such things alive right because your
future before any super resolution
techniques to preserving illusion
technique what do you have is a very
high resolution image also at that
sample of a fixed sample at that stuff
at the moment on a plane that's the most
of time you can get I mean how much you
can integrate is life a living process
from that information not enough ray and
then you will need you will want to have
a imager live dynamic 3d process alive
with high resolution and that's a
different challenge and that is a
project I was working on when I was in
Eric's lab and since that actually so
the differences between like something
as a very thin slice of some tissue over
one moment in time reverses
they're already dead versus something
that's alive yeah like Drosophila fruit
right able to image while it's alive
over time rather laners right you
testing by the way or you can say you
let's say you are having a HD image
that's a 4k image in your hands about a
football game or you prefer to say -
let's say - to watch the game at maybe
480 pixel resolution before for just one
play versus the whole game exactly
so basically actually one post right you
want you want the high-resolution live
video in heart process but at that point
of time 2010 there were some several
good live imaging techniques but a way
that sports analogy a lot right really
good one actually sure one seeing one
play of the game and trying to make some
inference about how the biology works
right versus watching the whole game in
high definition
exactly that's a really good yeah so
easy and we are collecting information
of the process life process right so
this and then that was the that same the
motivation of my project Hara started it
and of course at beginning why I joined
his lab me Erica gave me the idea called
passive inclination microscopy I mean I
I had so at that time I I have no idea
whether that's a good idea bad idea
working on not working idea but because
I have trust on him so I trust his idea
and I just I think I will be successful
it's just a falling here's the
instruction and making it happen I think
I will learn things so in the end I
worked very hard at that period time
that's another advice perhaps to most
people or young younger generations so
why John has led Eric asked me in his
email hey hey hey just the email me said
can you work 80 hours per week if you
cannot you don't come right you cannot
have anything down if you carry your
yes every single made to be honest when
works on something like 80 hours raker
mean I'm willing to do that I mean
because if I am I was not working for 80
hours per week
I said I'm actually wasting my time
because there's a reason I go there is I
want to learn that stuff right I want to
learn as quick as possible and I want to
learn from the best of scientists so I
won't waste my time so I push the front
eight year exact versus what would you
be doing yeah otherwise what woman watch
TV instead yeah exactly nothing more
interesting there's that work at some
point yeah so yeah not a problem at all
and I joined this lab and worked on that
project in indeed that was a very
fantastic bird I think we we were the
first group showing very indeed I mean
subcellular high-resolution a 3d live
process of cell behaviors substellar
behaviors etc so that was on in 2011 we
published our first paper about better
people in Malaysia Mycoskie on Nature
Methods with my colleagues sebacean with
Eric tastic and another colleague Thomas
pleasure
he's associate professor in Delaware
University now State University so yeah
so and at that time our group just have
three people so alpha as works on
project we indeed push the limit of that
technique and we Chen has read some very
cool stuff I think we initiate that
research direction of some of improve
the 3d image ability of lysine
microscopy by optimizing that like sheep
profile and the technique we use called
Paso beam plane nation microscopy and
also I think we were the first group
showing how fantastic it is if you can
indeed
watch the live biological process with
high spatial and temporal resolution and
after that me I think this field become
enormously attractive and popular
because people realize that while just
by a spatial resolution improvement you
cannot understand too much you have to
get it alive and you have to do
something under to understand the entire
process right that's pretty much what I
was doing during my post out research
with aerobatic yeah and now take us to
when you're doing your system
professorship at SUNY Stony Brook right
and you're doing tiling twin lattice
white sheets yeah
molecule is called hiding lysine my
crosby railing why treatment yeah so
that's a technique I invented while I
was assistant professor at Stony Brook
University the reason my research
migrated to that technique is because so
indeed we do have some awesome technique
res 3d live moon technique I was in
Eric's by this lab however the limit
that techniques also technique also had
had a lot of limitations so at the
beginning we we thought we want to
develop a light sheet techniques that
can image large specimens at a high
spatial resolution with high speed so we
can watch the dynamics of of biological
specimens rightfully them who we want to
study how embryos developed we want to
study how what neural activities in in a
brewing of labor fish etc so and then we
indeed we were pretty successful
developed some technique and applied
them to cellular specimens for example
we can image as a cultured cell on car
sleep very well we can image that kind
of a process very well but it was very
difficult to apply the same technique to
larger specimens for example zebrafish
embryos or C elegans embryos and some
some models that biologists use very
often to study biology question right so
basically you cannot get the same result
on multi-service specimens as you would
you can get all single service
placements and I was confused by why
that and I didn't get that answer
was doing post out in Eric's lab the
other question I was trying to answer a
song at the beginning you would be
pretty happy when you first seen those
dynamic process those videos write me
because it's just quite a fantastic to
see those lighting process but at some
point you would like to understand why
right because after saying what's
happening you always the next question
is always why these things are doing
those are doing that what what are they
doing what are those four molecules are
doing why the cell microwaves from a and
B and what reason cause that result
right you always want to answer this
question and you will find that even you
crack those the information if you don't
end lies them properly you won't be able
to use this information you have to
interpret the information in certain way
in order to reach a conclusion right
that's a second question I think we
didn't answer during my postal research
and then I start to work on this some
issues when I was at Stony Brook so
that's why how I started to work on 3d
imaging of large market specimens and a
heart start to work on quantitative
qualitative understanding of celery
behaviors in multicellular environments
the reason that is difficult let's say
the difficulties from several directions
firstly you want to study cells in their
native environment right
for example a embryo andrea has a lot of
cells right it's a very complete
environment it's it's like a it's you
can consider like a small society or a
community right people are interacting
with each other and people are doing
their own stuff but people are
communicating right as a the behavior of
individual cell or innovative person is
often result from other people inside
your own decision right it's the same
thing happening a multi-service specimen
and you have to gain that DT you have to
have tools to be able to collect those
information in order to understand them
right that's first the second is you
have to have a measure to understand to
organize the information and reach your
conclusion you have to have a model you
have to have certain way let's say
the destination of those behaviors and
you have helped my method and thus the
tool to analyze those be here to find
the relationship between them and that
that's a difficult or channel and now
this exists at that point at a time so
that's the motivation behind my research
and then of course the question is how
are you going to crack that information
that's a high spatial and temporal
resolution from large specimens right
and that's it one thing we learned in my
postal research is one may use our
technical I seen my kospi to image 3d
behavior we want to a key issue is you
want to create a large and sing like
[ __ ] in order to images 3d process well
because we have to scan that like sheet
across our sample but after five years
of research we finally realizes there's
no way you can create large and single
sheet at simple at the same time
basically means if we proceed along the
direction we have been during my postal
research we won't be able to achieve
this goal so this looks like a piece of
tissue that you're imaging and your
shining laser right it's through it in a
very thin sheet right and then that's
lighting it up in these images right so
basically imagine you have out here a I
want to see stated layer by layer right
what I need to do is I can try a very
single layer of light to a selective
plane of that tissue and I scan the
layer across the sample I capture a lot
of images and I get a high-resolution
image of that sample right but how you
can create a single layer of light laser
is an important question but in the end
we realized no you cannot create a thing
of light over long distance so my
technique called highly noisy my kospi
was yes we cannot create a long and
single layer of light but we can created
we can create a short but staying layer
of light and then what we are doing is
we scan that move that layer of light
quickly wheezing the image plane and
then you capture multiple images right
by doing that your it's equivalent to a
let's virtual large and single sheet and
by using this strategy you are able to
image large multicellular specimens with
high resolution so your your modulating
this this laser light from a point to
another point to another point exactly
and then cat imaging as you modulate it
to those different exactly exactly so
basically that's another thing let's say
it's a compromise of life basically at
beginning we were looking for something
perfect right we want high resolution we
want high speed we want to image these
things for very long period of time and
with high signal signal to noise ratio
but at some point you will realize it's
impossible it's a it's just like
everything right it's sometimes very
difficult when you ask for everything
but if you can think about exactly
what's most important see for a specific
moment or for some specific experiment
you always find that you can sacrifice
something so in 10 tiny light sheet
microscopy what you are sacrificing
because you have to move light in the
field of view and your sacrifice or your
in your speed a little bit but because
the technique is already fast you can
you're still can maintain a reasonable
speed to to finish that image process
and because if you don't do that
compromise you cannot see it you get
nothing but this is technique yes you
compromise something but you gain
something at the same time and another
advantage of this technique is that you
can you can basically you have very
large freedom to decide I mean how stick
that like she is how fast you want to
how it so you can have great flexibility
to optimize the experiment and then by
doing that you have more chance to get
the information you want from a
biological process and thereafter you
can start to create your model and you
can analyze your 3d images and start
understand the relationship between them
that's another reason actually why 3d
imaging is important for quantitative
analysis because if you don't capture
entire process in 3d if you only capture
a certain plan yes you can guess you can
have a pretty good guess about what's
happening but you will not be able to
exactly
let's say define the exactly quality or
that's annoying what's going on let's
say you cannot draw that scientific
conclusion in the end you have you only
can describe what's happening yeah let's
have you explain also that when you are
aiming to use tiling light sheet
microscopy to image a nice of tissue
okay that there are already a tremendous
amount of points that you have to
modulate yes a laser exactly to image so
let's talk about the number of points
that you think are in like even just
something as small as the fruit fly
right and then next after you teach us
about how many points there are teach us
about how you then it's based on how
many points there are and how much data
is stored is based on yes and the
nanometer resolution then capturing that
also teaches about that process so
actually a question also related to my
later career decisions
so what's explained that's trajectory
then because this is to westlake yes yes
oh so I vented this technique at Stony
Brook University right and it was
patented and actually that patent was
granted this year so I developed that
technique it was a pretty successful
applied to some small specimens like
some embryos etc but of course embryos
are pretty simple simple multi-service
specimens you do want to understand more
or complicated lives right for example
mouse mouse brain I'll just elaborate
how they think how they make decisions
etc and that high in reserve is a big
another big problem you have to overcome
is let's say scattering of the light or
let's say both the scattering and
aberration of light let's say basically
the light cannot penetrate through the
tissue right it can only penetrate the
mouth maybe several hundred microns and
then it's completely scattered you won't
be able to get any high resolution
information from based on the technique
we have today and then I was actually
pretty I was kind of disappointed at the
point
because I saw that you have something
quite important however if you only can
apply them to for example C elegans
embryos or to the zebrafish at the best
land your technique has a pretty limited
impact right because you cannot use it
to study more complicated animal models
means right and the impact is something
we have been looking for but as
important the meaning may be in 2016
from a collaboration I I learned about
technique called teacher clearing
technique so multiple labs are working
on that technique so basically with that
technique you are able to make tissue
transparent although they are fixed so
they are dad's best mean but they are
transparent right if they're transparent
means you can you really can start to
use lie to get a 3d structure of those
tissues which is something very
difficult to do me are almost impossible
to do before this technique was
developed because before that what the
best people can do is people have to cut
the tissue slice by slice of course you
can imagine amount of work you have to
do and the limitations aren't there so
basically not not many people are doing
that and then this is tissue current
technique you suddenly have the
possibility to apply the latest 3d
high-speed 3d high-resolution imaging
technique to gain the structure after
all kinds of tissues right for example
your brain may not mean not human brain
yet but for the mouse brain organs he
and you can start a humorous etc so many
different possibilities and then I say
while this must be the future of this
technique because it's indeed a limited
the barrier that prevents this technique
to be able apply to a larger field to
make more impact array and I can see a
lot of let's say commercial potentials
of this technique and then that's why I
decide to switch my direction career
direction and and and also the research
direction at the same time so I after
that I join a technique company called
Surya IRA and i exac company I use my
technique because I have everything in
my mind about what instrument I want to
build hi I'm could really use my
technique right and indeed I studied how
to use my tiny lights in microscopy
technique just to image tissues and
indeed we mean this is a very natural
transit but applying this tiling she
likes to microscopy and then apply them
on tissue imaging we can image large
large clear teachers for example mouse
brain because it's a centimeter size
level right it's it's a very large set
actually in aspect to imaging with very
high resolution however also the spatial
resolution was great I realized several
problems the first problem is on is a
time you have to spend in order to get
that information because the sample is
so large I mean why want high resolution
right if you do a calculation you will
funny it's going to take hours even days
in order to get a cellular level
resolution of a few micron and because
of we are you doing a tiling process
cutting process is something either
sided mean you sacrifice the time to
gain the resolution right but at some
point that time that price become too
high for example if you let's say for a
small specimen if it used to take one
minute notice that you spend five
minutes it's okay because the four means
more right but if we used to spend one
hour now expanded to five hours then
that's a significant deal because four
hours is a lot of time you don't want to
spend right and as that's one issue I
start to think about how to how to
overcome and the next thing is of course
about the data size again because of the
sample is so large and you want to get a
high-resolution typical size of data you
are have to collect and analyze this at
least at hundreds of gigabytes level and
very easily goes 2 terabytes or PV level
provides level and then that lets say
that's this are the still frontier
problems that unsolved and people are
trying to solve and we are trying to
solve and actually fortunately we that
this is something about our latest
research actually about how you're
overcoming exactly if you imagine the
process of hiding elijah imagine this
absolutely alright I have like [ __ ] I
want to tell it 1 2 3 4 times in order
to get in her plain image right it takes
four times round longer time to image
the plane higher also despite my
resolutions higher but is there anything
we how can we accelerate process our
latest technique called discontinuous
slide sheet so basically instead of
using ones like [ __ ] we are using a
group of light [ __ ] for example let's
say each of my finger represents Elijah
Dre so if you want to if you only have
one finger you want to put them in time
positions but now you have five you only
need to move them once and you can get
everything down so that's how and by
doing that you your speed can be
improved dramatically right and you
don't lose that at resolution anyway you
still keep that resolution and this is
actually our latest result we were
pretty excited about it
and we get it submitted yesterday Wow
this idea was in my mind for a long time
while I was hours in Shriya but because
of the let's say the decisions in your
companies always it's it's decided it
means determined by traffic right is
there nothing wrong with it so in your
company you have to make a profit to
survive but how to make profit and how
the decision about let's say there is
short term profit you know there is a
long term profit and meanwhile me for
any company you will need to decide
what's at any point of the company some
company will be satisfied with let's say
stay with 2030 people and survive as
long as possible and then people would
be happy with that kind of business but
at some point to me in my idea because
thing about begin
why I decided to do this tissue imaging
was a blank area and nobody was able to
do it easily before now suddenly we have
so many let's say good technique and ooh
gain tissue structures on its high
resolution and weekends we can get an
immediately got so much abundant
information about our body right about
all kinds of different tissues that
information is a fortune I think it can
lead us to a complete understanding in
power size and relate to our our health
and for clinical applications this is
that diagnostic etc because Steve's
array and then that means you can
correlate you can connect this two
billion dollar even trillion dollar
business and that is the impact I think
all the future I'm looking for I'm not
sure whether it going to happen or not
but I think I mean there will be enough
smart people see this kind of future and
we'll be working on it and to me because
I think I understand this technique and
I understand the direction I would like
to be involved in this process and I
would like to develop the key technique
or is it and meanwhile I believe there
will be other people working on
different sets of problem to make the
entire protocol executable on humans or
on large areas and in the end if we
combine our solution together we can we
can make something we can basically
change things dramatically right we can
we can we can make some pretty on
dramatic influence or our change yes so
then is it then taking multiple lasers
and locations that are just far enough
away from each other where you don't
experience the issues with diffraction
and yeah
that's that's a very good question
actually that's a key question indeed
you have to separate them far enough you
can they cannot be too close to avoid it
in order to avoid the indifference speed
between them and we do have a basically
user a device called spatial light
modulator and we
some verbs include Messel to operate
that device to generate the life is that
this come in your slide should we want
so it can behaving in ways that we will
like it to behave actually there are
some more ideas we will apply to this
tag actually which are come together
here but actually we can further improve
the speed and resolution of this
technique because even with this
development if you think about it to get
high resolution result from mouse brain
so our goal is to get to image in high
mouse purring with less than hundred
nanometers spatial resolution even with
this improvement it going to take years
to have the entire sample image it's not
fast enough
we want to keep the resolution but we
need the throughput to be higher and
then you guys have ideas too exactly
which is what we are working on in order
to make this thing happen why that is
important because after you gain that
ability you will be able to understand
all let's say the goal is to understand
how mine is generated in our brain right
how decisions are generated and you have
to understand that neural circuit in
order to gain this information it has to
be fast enough to only because there are
all kinds of different behaviors right
so you have to make the through the high
enough to be able to image study all
different types of behaviors and again
extract that information from from the
nature from Mouse from other kind of
model animals maybe fish right at some
point maybe from ourselves so that's why
this kind of ability is so important and
we are going to put all of our resource
in order to achieve this goal
so that's something what we are working
on and we think we have ideas about how
to make it happen there are risks but
the west lake is a one of the best place
to that they gave us a resource the the
support as a hundred percent to let us
do what we want and make things happen
that's why one reason actually I decide
to join this university because again
what we have this
you need the freedom you need the
support you need the resource to to make
it happen the part left to Ozzy's work
hard yes yes Westlake is a place of
great magic Oh interdisciplinary magic
yes it's beautiful and now you have two
research assistants three phd's right
now you guys are pushing the edge
further and further in the field the
frontier further and further this
discontinuous lightsheet well that is a
very interesting addition to tiling it's
really interesting it's taking right now
our imaging at as low as a hundred no no
meter yes resolution but we were talking
about this before we started in your lab
right that this is still not doing the
molecular side of things the the
neurochemical right side of things and
like something like the brain right so
the imaging is is excellent and that's
gonna have to be overlaid eventually
also with the neurochemical even like
Euler side of things as well and that
will give us the full picture exactly so
we are doing our job so I think this is
come and gone many research labs for men
a lot of tops in research labs in in
United States in Japan Genelia Harvard
MIT mean Tokyo University a lot in
Europe a lot of groups are having this
common goal and trying to achieve this
goal right the indeed labeling is a very
important issue we're trying to work on
this if problems I believe many other
people start working on this problem as
well so we are willing to see what
solution because I believe this there
are so many people that are smarter than
us they are going to gave us new
insights new solution at same time we
are doing our best and the England
meanwhile we are creating all the best
Messer product for example a master
called expansion microscopy we're also
trying to use that so with all this
everybody work together I mean as
and come to our very first your very
first question right we all contribute
the best part of our efforts and by
combining combining our solutions we may
have this problem solved which is yeah
we are excited to be a part of this this
community and we are honored to be able
to contribute yes it is so cool being
able to go to the different labs and
basically learn how as you push a
frontier
someone else can take what you're doing
and implement it in their exacta and you
guys are just a couple hundred meters
away from each other
exactly and that's how you can create
this this this community of frontier
pushing faster right yeah that's such a
beautiful piece yeah yeah I believe
because I have been following research
works of many dewlaps I think there are
people following me and yeah actually
it's a small it seems to be a big board
but in these days it's so small yeah so
to me I mean I I don't feel I'm at a
different location of the ward I mean my
feeling is I'm still in this society
that connect with each other so and
let's also explain how you for the for
the technology that was made with the
tiling light sheet microscopy it's
available for non-commercial yes use yes
this is a very important so scientists
from around the world can ask you for
permission yes as long as I design the
software everything Lucien the whole
process right right right yes I think
this is our responsibility obligation to
contribute to the society about what we
know what we learn because let's say
first from my own aspect we are
developing tools and Masur right I mean
in order to make let's say 90% or 95% of
method dying in nowhere nobody knows the
existence of that nobody remember them
they just disappear before scientists
who are
it was developing on Massa you don't
want that happen right you definitely
want your technique to country
positively to sign of your research
right to make that impact so that's one
reason I feel I want to push my
technique to more research labs I have
that belief that we are doing the best
imaging technique and I want to want
people to take the benefit of our own
research so myself we can satisfaction
from this process right the second is we
are obligated to do this because again
best literacy is funded by private
donors and some tax dollars as well as
well I mean this in my opinion this is a
long-term investment of the society to
significant research because what's a
fundamental reason that people are doing
research is curiosity
it's it there is not much say I let's
say very few good researchers are funded
or let's say produce them because we
know what was a return right a lot of
them just divide me or established based
on our curiosity but we all know that
our curiosity in a long term a long run
going to return our society going to
have a return that is unpredictable
right that is kind of investment that is
let's say the contractor we are holding
in raise the entire society so for that
reason indeed our techniques they be
distributed through two ways way
commercially and non-commercial
distribution commercially we do have new
technique patented and license to
companies to to make it happen because
for some people even they have
everything they won't build a instrument
it's all have their focus it's all have
their ability and they don't have time
to spend all that they did rather to to
buy instead of spending their time to to
build because time is money right times
merfolk for a lot of people it more
valuable than money but for other labs
for many a lot
didn't use it for different purposes
that's why we are giving our entire
design software everything to research
labs for non-commercial use we are happy
very happy actually we are honoring the
two to do that actually this is also
something I learned from postdoc advisor
aerobatic in Genelia hates doing that I
mean I'm happy to inherit that tradition
and to basically to to reach return of
knowledge to the society not only to to
China or mean to to everyone in the
world I think yes that that's that's our
belief I love that part about your
vision it's so important to communicate
that around the world as we push the
frontier of science we can open up our
technology and tools that we've pushed
the frontier with to enable thousands of
other people from around the world to
use those to keep pushing the frontier
to advance it faster and to democratize
the benefits across the world to all
people right let's talk about the
democratized benefits as well you told
me that it would be so cool to see this
technology be able to be used and
approved for healthcare purposes around
the world right how cool would it be to
be able to see my tissues my biometrics
or even our family members because most
often it's our parents or our
grandparents health issues yeah and then
we say scientists doctors please save my
family and so the idea is that maybe
what you have some sort of an issue
going on with your body with your
family's bodies now you can use great
technologies like yours at the hospitals
once they are FDA approved to be able to
take an image those parts of our of our
health and then be able to do things
like run artificial intelligence
calculations to identify patterns
predict pathology and
all different things I love tell us
about this big picture vision for for
augmenting our health so this is a let's
say first of all this is kind more or
less like a gut feeling right so why why
I think this going to this kind of
ability let's say clack high-resolution
tissue even information from human body
going to mean something if significant
because we don't know our body very well
I mean with this kind of knowledge about
the cellular structure even set the sub
cellular structure of different human
tissues of our body we are going to
learn a lot of things about our health
condition about genetic functions about
why we are they behave differently etc
we don't know right because we never had
that information but from our
experiences it's always like when you do
have more information you have the
chance to understand more about yourself
about let's say about life so that's a
belief in my mind so I'd rather to take
the risk I mean of course I'm trying to
sell in this concept at the same time
and of course at this point we do have
the chance to do it now because of
kyushu clearing because of a
high-resolution 3d imaging of course
there are several problem you want to
overcome at same time right people will
say well me why people would like you to
cut their tissue to do this kind of
analysis or hardening to label them
right I mean actually there are people
working on these problems already I mean
I cannot tell you exactly for example at
least we know we can cut your skin red
mean people if you can skin cancer is is
one of the most dangerous cancer among
the world right especially in the US I
mean if I don't think people with money
if you cut a small piece of skin and be
able to know his chance to to to get
skin cancer and sexual right I mean with
the ability we can do that a for example
when people are doing surgery I mean
people won't mind if you cut smaller TV
or me it won't hurt them right and then
there are a lot of ways to do that and
people can develop better protocols and
by those doctors or biologists and they
live there's enough smart people to have
this problem solved and then what we can
offer what we can offer is we can image
that last piece of tissue in minutes
with the resolution that actually we can
do that right now and we are our
technique is pretty unique actually in
the in the way of application it's it
has a very strong self alignment ability
so basically that instrument make sure
it works that by itself and then why
that's this is important because people
who are going to operate the instrument
going to be doctors going to be people
who'll never be trained to do scientific
research and we think this is very
important for this technique to be to be
used in hospitals in clinics as well
right and then how are you going to use
that it mean let's say after you give
this analysis ability how are you going
to execute this analysis ability I mean
we are trying to create a network like
social medium I mean our big planet mean
is something it's a pie in the sky right
now but that's some definitely something
I'm trying to come with some people to
do is me when we have that ability more
short we are trying to push it let's say
we are giving this technique we are
killing this instrument to hospitals to
clinics free mean and then we are we
give them standard protocol so everybody
can use the same protocol to crack the
information and we are trying to build a
cloud system based on all this
instrument imagine if you have a solvent
ring 0 maybe 20 30 solving the hospitals
perhaps more my number may not be
accurate in in China or maybe there are
more Hospital worldwide right if all
this hospital has to one a couple of
this equipment and the work mean
routinely high efficiently may
administer level to correct this kind of
issue
this kind of information from different
tissues from different disease that
issue etc different organs etc
we will have huge very valuable database
about ourselves about human and then I
believe we are going to get something
very important information out of this
database I mean that's our big goal I
think I think this this is this going to
be the fortune this is going to the
future of this technique the application
of this technique at the human health
level at this is diagnostic level etc
people may have even better ideas at
that point the time of course when we
are talking about crack that issue let's
say structure information from from
human beings it's going to have a lot of
other issues for example the privacy
right and how this kind of application
can be regulated well and how the
information can be used wisely etc being
on this is another thing that going to
require better understanding
communication and and regulation between
different labs different countries and
in the scientist right so that's
something I mean it it is highly
important it's exciting and it requires
collaboration requires vision requires
passion and that's something we like to
do yeah open up the big data silos
around the world and help make the
pattern patterns be able to be
recognized better have the constant
stream of biometrics from our health be
able to be analyzed to predict
pathologies I wanted to see if maybe
there was a way like your with your mass
spectrometry taking it down from 100
kilograms to 5 kilograms if maybe there
was a way to do it with tiling light
sheet microscopy where instead of having
to do it in the hospitals I could
basically maybe wear something around me
with me all the time that would allow
dynamic capture exactly the dimension of
time exactly first of all I say we
indeed we are working our instrument is
not expensive let's say for some basic
models the raw cost day is about
$100,000 that it's not a small amount
money but compared to most scientific
instrument it's a cheap device and it
has a lot of function
secondly we indeed have solutions to
make it even cheaper so we indeed can
give it out for free right that's a very
important thing but to last them the
most important thing is if it's indeed
me so valuable I mean nobody really care
about the price I don't think price is
the first concern when people decide to
do something right for those big
companies private companies what when
they decide to put billion dollars of
investment on something for example
Facebook Google or Apple when they
decide to invest on something I don't
think the the profit is a big factor but
profits not perhaps not the most
important factor a single impact Jim is
it is the most important factor because
let's say money at some point is very
important but after some point money is
not the important issue at all for for
for many for many people for many
companies or all countries because money
at some point it's it's paper it's pink
printed paper money is printed based our
confidence on our economy our behavior
and that's our behavior is actually the
basis of economy right if we need a
certain amount of basic needs that we
want to start spreading impact exactly
so so I at that point I mean if we
indeed can prove this or something
internally important available I don't
think we will be lack of support or
money to do it so in yeah after all we
have to prove this is a this is a good
way to go this is something we can spend
our time and efforts yeah yeah yeah
how about on the way out let's ask some
questions how can we inspire more people
to collaborate together or
yeah that's a that's a good question
everybody should ask themselves I should
ask myself me because sometimes people
are mad at things for no reason right
you mad at other people mad at their
family members mad at yourself at some
point so let's see yeah let's go back to
our first discuss first the question
again but we talked about the regulation
right
I mean basically perhaps we all have to
think about what's the most important
thing in our life what we are looking
for what's important because the reason
to make that question clear is because
after you know what exact thing you want
what's important to you you can get rid
of the disturbance easier so you won't
be disturbed by many in trivial things
anymore and the way you are not
disturbed by those unimportant few
things when you are very focused on your
goal I think you have better control on
your temper you have better
understanding on people and you have
better motivation to to work positively
or constructively with people from
different background or mine so I think
that's a very important thing about how
we can collaborate or work together
better I guess in order to make that
happen you have to understand yourself
better right you have to understand
what's important to you what you're what
you want and what you can compromise in
this kind of collaboration right that's
a perhaps the most critical part and of
course in English that's some other
education concept that we trying to
let's say embedded into our school is we
have to learn that when we work
constructively zeroD there is win-win
situation right so basically one plus
one could be larger than one we can if
we indeed work together with good honest
we can we can make things happen
Gimenez the faster and nicer right
groove apart for everyone exactly which
is very very important see the second
important thing is if you have the
belief of winning situations and
negotiation how to negotiate how to
resolve disagreement is another
employment skill we all have to learn
right so basically you you have you have
to understand yourself better understand
your partner better and to have the
discriminant solve in a way that
everybody maybe have to compromise
something but you also gain what you
want is through that collaboration so
basically understand yourself try to
understand others and have the good
belief let's say a common belief of ring
ring situation I think it's the basis of
of the interaction between different
people and between different country
what widely I think yeah I think indeed
in English some in the world today I
think this is this is very important
person concept that everybody should
learn should ya include ourselves I
guess we should yeah yeah yes likewise
yeah it's really great how about what do
you think is the meaning of life this
big human experiment right so yeah this
is a this is a good question because at
different period of time maybe we have a
different answer to that question right
but as this special moment I think I I
was let's say while I was a student that
I trying to get into a good colleague I
think perhaps that's a good meaning of
my life
and then while I was in college I was
trying to find a good job and where I
was I got my PhD or I trying to get a
good payment a good salary perhaps
that's very important to my life but at
some point I mean none of those song
let's say none of those are the pursuit
of those goals going to make going to
last very long or going to make your
happy at some point I realized perhaps I
mean my career
complicated I did a lot of different
things I think in the end I I have been
I have been looking for a better myself
I have been trying to reach a better
performance actually there are a couple
movies that I like and I like their
concept about let's say looking for a
better performance
looking for a better version of yourself
because we have a limited life I want to
see what's a if if I train myself if I
did in a way that I sing I regulate in a
way that I think I'm going to activist
I want to see what's the best I can
actually at that point right so there
was a good movie about it it's called a
free soul or as we worshipped right that
guy trying to climb over cliffs
I mean without any protection me seems
to be crazy guy but I think I can
understand him because he said some
people look for happiness sitting in
their life and some people work for look
for performance right yeah I think I'm
one of them looking for why after the
guys looking for performance that's
that's I think motivation can last a
longer and make me excited and another
movie actually maybe it's extended
helping it go too far and it's called
gladiator so gladiators if you at some
point people wish think gladiators are
slaves right there is fight to death
this pretty cell life but you but if you
think about it look look at the history
if you think about them I mean at some
point they they don't feel sad means
their credit see they are they are dying
in your glory right so at some point if
you think about the meaning of life
everybody come to die at some point
right you and me you don't know what
happened it happened to your life you
don't know when it came to be the end of
your of your life right and then when
does Clara read her fight evaluate her
fights what's in their mind they are
thinking about the death of glory right
so what they are saying is he'll Caesar
people about to die salute you
right I think at some point we are
already
at the point so we salute to our life
sorry we want that glory in the end so
that's the meaning of life yes
beautifully said okay and then what do
you think consciousness is you mean how
that happens yeah yeah that's a question
actually we are trying to understand
right that's why we are doing all these
kind of reasons yeah this is very
interesting because you think about
what's a difference of yes so if you
think about ourselves
what are we we are a group of molecules
where we are a molecule assemblies
that's all right that's all right but at
some point these molecules have mind as
conscious as it is that we're trying to
do crazy things and and try to
understand ourselves whether that's
indeed a very interesting so basically
again as we discuss a little bit as it
includes two parts right and he include
a execution about the chemical reactions
about the how the signal strength
transferred by electron or by eyes etc
is actual signals and it included
another part of which is a algorithm
that the logic that dominates this
execution execution right and then this
part basically the logic and the
execution of the logical form our mind
floating from and direct our behavior
right and then where this is this come
from and whether we can understand it in
the end
I I think I have no answer I don't I
don't know although we are trying to
understand it mmm but indeed this can
can drive me can drive it can drive our
behavior for a very long time I can
drive our research motivation for land
hire but in the end if at some point we
indeed understand how its formed highest
credit and maybe I will appeal it the
upset as a point I said because then
what else you can do
if there's plenty more to push the
frontier right after that yeah what do
you think that we are in a simulation
yeah and you mean about metrics right I
mean I don't know but what's the
difference it doesn't make difference
right that's a that's a that's a let's
say is that a serious answer I've no
actually I like that movie I indeed like
that aspect of perspective of rethinking
our life but we cannot i I think I we
perhaps cannot rule out the possibility
right because our understanding is so
limited meaning if yeah we think we know
a lot of sense at this point but if you
mean we are but I think maybe human
beings are always at this kind of
exaggerated status we think we know a
lot we actually we don't know much we
become arrogant at some point but
perhaps we were right yeah if you indeed
even by the mmm even for a question you
you just answer right how much we know
about ourselves not much great we really
don't know I mean maybe it's just a
start of way of a long journey and we
don't know if how long this journey
going to be able to be last right
because meanwhile people are doing crazy
things I mean there are people doing
positive things there are negative since
happening eventually is quite a chaotic
Society on the other hand so yeah maybe
that's why life is interesting right but
yeah as I'm not why people some people
start to think positively people some
people started saying it negatively or
this truck this constructively
destructively me yeah all these are good
questions were self study it means yeah
in the end the research I guess that's
why a single research is not about it's
not about science it's not about
technology it's really about curiosity
understanding or reality exactly it's I
think that's a fundamental reason of of
science is our base our curiosity of
course I seen
for us it's a it's a luxury I mean it's
a mmm it's an it's a yeah indeed I mean
we
it's our how to say that so we had this
opportunity the cable opportunity to
have a good environment to be able to
answer these questions we have the
resource to be spend two to do
experimental one we are on asking and I
think this extremely on pressures on
opportunities that we should really use
this resources well - yeah - to give a
good answer on them yes and then what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world most beautiful saying there
are so many what are they I mean perhaps
life right
perhaps lives a someone if you ask me
what's a beautiful thing
my what's reflecting my mind immediately
are my children's yes
so you see how they develop from nothing
and to a life to a human that has a lot
of thinking's have their own will me I
asking this this this is its this
process is so so beautiful yes yeah
perhaps out life is a beautiful most
beautiful thing of this world I think
yeah indeed right that's we are what we
are doing right me indeed there is no
more a more complex saying than
than ourselves and me exactly it's magic
yeah they're thinking about our children
as just this cell that is goes and
becomes a living breathing thinking
exactly meaning in life right right it
becomes a part of yeah yeah you still
remember the days in our baby and now I
some probably can argue with you and we
kept our jokes with you and we can yeah
me and they have different personality
and that way yeah very yeah I mean
that's also that's amazing for yeah my
boys mean my other side especially me
it's such a interesting for me I I just
enjoy the conversation with him a lot of
times to me yeah so I yes indeed this is
such a beautiful saying yes yes
thank you so much thank you so much yes
nice conversation which pleasure thank
you thank you yes you and thank you for
all your incredible work thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about tiling
light sheet microscopy about these new
optical methods that enable rapid
high-resolution 3d imaging of expanded
biological specimens and also check out
the links in the bio below to Westlake
University check out the links in
viability layin GAO's work as well check
that out and also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the organizations
around the world that you believe and
support them and help them grow you can
find our links in the bio below as well
you can help support us so we can
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to incredible places like
Westlake University and conducting
interviews of some of the most brilliant
minds and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in thank you and we will see
you soon thank you
good that was so good
thank you so much
[Music]
you
[Music]